[Musique]
tu veux que je prêt à décoller puis il a
fait son retour est plutôt chat tout
arranger je parte pour cause encore et
encore la tante tue parce que je comme
pas accepté ces excuses polytoxicomane
claude attend avec impatience d'une
place au centre de traitement des
dépendances senti du nouveau jour à
l'anti dans les laurentides
à 64 ans il a déjà fait plusieurs sur
d'autres il est au bout du rouleau il
demande de l'aed dans la brousse ou
aubrespy ce type entre impôts pour que
les couples y rester
à cause de la crevette 19 environ la
moitié des ressources en dépendance la
province ont cessé les nouvelles
admissions
malgré le fait qu'elles soient
considérées comme prioritaires par le
gouvernement du québec plusieurs centres
n'ont pas les ressources nécessaires
pour rouvrir le dr jean-robert pionnier
de la médecine communautaire au québec à
livrer une cargaison d'équipements de
protection provenant de sa clinique de
saint jérôme il espère ainsi accélérer
la reprise des admissions du sentier du
nouveau jour depuis le début de la crise
le centre est en confinement et est
incapable d'accueillir de nouveaux
résidents une personne qui a cogné à sa
porte est morte de surdose la fermeture
des admissions causées des des
catastrophes
le système les eaux sur la conscience je
ne dis pas les gens qui travaillent dans
le système mais la structure aussi des
scellés sur la conscience
citant tech le système en est sûrs à
l'âge de 81 ans le docteur robert
continue de visiter ces patients dans
les années 60 après avoir contracté la
tuberculose il a vécu un an en
sanatorium le confinement
il connaît des villes j'en ai déjà vu
l'eau oui je fais attention au pays si
je l'attrapé ben coudon depuis plus d'un
mois les membres du syndicat des
travailleurs et travailleuses en
interventions communautaires demandent
au gouvernement de l'équipement de
protection il financements nécessaires
pour assurer la sécurité des
intervenants et de la clientèle
il ya quelques jours ils ont organisé un
coup d'éclat à la direction régionale de
santé publique à montréal avec le
resserrement des contrôles aux
frontières l'approvisionnement en drogue
est aujourd'hui plus difficilement
possible du monde entier puisse racheter
10 rebonds
jeudi dernier le ministère de la santé
et des services sociaux a annoncé une
aide d'urgence de 3 millions de dollars
qui sera versée aux ressources
d'hébergement aux dépendances il
souligne que le québec ne semble pas
être en situation d'excès de surdoses de
drogue ou de piau id mais les
intervenants du milieu communautaire
crainte aujourd'hui une nouvelle crise
il faut bien se rappeler qu'un centre
comme ici et là pour les gens de la rue
pour les toxicomanes pour les junk et
comme on dit c'est l'europe sial mais
quand il appelle en urgence le soir et
le samedi
c'est une urgence puis quand on leur dit
non mais c'est l'équivalent de fermino
hôpitaux